selber sechs kids und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video in dem
sich heute das größte gebäude in
minecraft vorstellen möchte und zwar ist
die ganze angelegenheit imperials city
erstmal vorweg ein paar fakten jetzt ein
bisschen recherchiert so jetzt nicht
ewig bin ja auch kein journalist oder
sowas sondern habe ich ein bisschen
umgeguckt und das hier scheint das
größte gebäude in minecraft zu sein
natürlich gibt es wahrscheinlich
irgendwo in brasilien jemand im urwald
der auf einem rechner lokalen größeres
gebäude gebaut hat und ihr kennt ihr
zufällig nie wirklich wenn er irgendwie
beute kennt was noch größer ist als das
hier noch aufwendige dann könnten die
kommentare schreiben
das hier zeichnet sich vor allem dadurch
aus dass es vielleicht nicht
flächenmäßig von der ausdehnung her am
krassesten ist aber dass es mit sehr
viel liebe zum detail gebaut ist und da
sehr viel arbeitszeit rhein geflossen
ist das heft game ist gigantisch groß
ist 120 megabyte für diesen
speicherstand wenn euch darunter leidet
dass er die welt auf spielen wollt ist
übrigens unter der beschreibung wurde am
dritten november 2012 zum ersten mal
auch keine minecraft gepostet es gibt
sogar ein eigenes texture pack dafür
erst mal hier
das ist der sport quasi und city hat für
windows and the city version for team
von zero
das sind die lead designer regale und
kommen wir haben einen per post der
heißt so manni mental imperial city und
der ist unfassbar beliebt ich glaube
ihrem fast 800.000 downloads auf der map
also die map ist wirklich wirklich was
krasses das kann kein zufall sein wenn
so viele leute das feiern mit den fans
da sind wir eine besonderheit denn das
entwicklerteam kommt glaube ich zu 100
prozent aus frankreich weil wir können
meine kinder meine nachricht anders an
das französische entwickler team
schreiber
schauen wir uns mal ein bisschen um
sodass hier sieht echt cool aus mainz
montiert das sind direkt zur
venezianische gondeln ja immer so ein
kanal und ich bin hier schon ein
bisschen um geflogen auf der map in der
vorbereitung für das video und mir ist
aufgefallen dass es sehr sehr viele
gebäude gibt die sehr realitätsnah sind
also die quasi ein gebäude aus der
realität erinnern so welche das sind
wenn wir gleich selbst herausfinden da
könnt ihr auch unten den kommentaren mit
raten weil ich nicht so dass aktuelle
oberbrechen architektur bin wenn ihr
smarter seite als ich könnte das einfach
in die kommentare schreiben treppen
einfach so die uhrzeit die uhrzeit hsk
du kleiner pisser es war nicht das und
das gebäude dass er das und das gebäude
okay das ist der kanal hier da haben ja
von der bibliothek der handys unter
wasser
das hier soll glaube ich venedig sein
das ist eine klassische venezianische
gondel der gondoliere ist leider nicht
da es ausprobieren
gondoliere unbekannter befehle alles
klar
so und jetzt große preisfrage an was
erinnert das gebäude hier
das ist quasi das paradies pont da unten
und dieses gebäude ist direkt eine
besonderheit denn so wie ich das
verstanden habe oder wie ich sehe ist
dass ihr reichsadler der zum beispiel
auch im bundestag erhängt und das hier
oben ist vielleicht die die quadriga auf
dem brandenburger tor oben ist heißt das
es effektiv so eine mischung aus
reichstag oder bundestag und
brandenburger tor und irgendwelchen
chinesischen pagoden da oben also es ist
wirklich wirklich glaubt übrigens leute
mal ganz abgesehen davon dass hier ein
dinosaurier ist ein t rex und pocking
harmuth davon abgesehen leute seid so
gut und schreibt man die kommentare wie
ihr solche videos hier findet man mir
quasi irgendwas besonderes bei minecraft
raussuchen und euch dann vorstellen im
video
während ihres cool findet ihr es
generell nicht so cool bin da immer für
feedback offen das könnt ihr mir gerne
und in die kommentare schreiben
das ist wichtig damit auch so ein flug
dino also leute ihr seht schon was ich
meine wenn ich sage mit viel
detailverliebtheit im interieur gebaut
aber das ist echt schön gebäude ich
meine das ist nur ein gebäude von vielen
und von innen sieht das jetzt aus wie so
ein museum das museum in new york
national history museum nachts im museum
diese szene mit dem mammut in dem
tiebreaks in diesem flug dino jetzt kann
überlegen okay da vorne ist ein
venezianischer kanal
quasi ist das dann hier das gibt auch
irgendwo irgend so eine brücke in
florenz oder so glaube ich gibt
irgendeine berühmte brücke in florenz
oder in venedig die genauso aussieht ich
weiß nicht welches ist wie gesagt eine
idee hat ab in die kommentare damit ist
das regio drei lego 2 vl will legio rex
rex lateinisch für könig aber ist aus
dieser gegrüßt und regio ist es ist
irgendwas denkmal warum es schon wieder
der reichsadler hier
das kann ich jetzt gerade echt nicht
zuordnen soll das ist es der koloss von
rhodos nein ist echt geil also das echte
natur durch die menschliche
architekturgeschichte eigentlich es ist
so spannend also diese map lohnt sich
wirklich finde ich alles klar hier
einfach ein panzer deal ende
warum so viele panzer die tanks laden so
viel schneller wenn man da draußen hat
irgendwie panzerfabrik vielleicht eine
deutsche panzer von brig keine ahnung
dann hier einfach einen burgturm alter
schwede
also ihr könnt wirklich in jede richtung
fliegen in jeder richtung einfach so
gigantisch viele denken wir dass es
unfassbar dass das schachbrett mit
kritikern aber cool wie die wirklich
genau auf den feldern draufstehen seht
ihr das alter schwede
das ist ja auch richtig krass gebaut
holly schildmann das ist echt heftig
heute solche bauwerke einfach jede
subotic 89
das hier ist es die freiheitsstatue
hermann schwert in der hand aber ich
will zeigen dass die freiheitsstatue
gerade wenn die so weit aus dem wasser
steht und die haben wir irgend einen
riesigen leuchtturm und der erinnert
mich irgendwie solche ledig also sie zu
griechische aus von der bauweise mit
diesen blau gibt es irgendwie berühmten
griechischen leuchtturm ab irgendeinem
davon wissen alles gigantische
dimensionen so drüber weg denkt man sich
das nicht aber diesen gigantisch groß
die ganzen bauwerke was ist das hier für
migrantische style moment meist dass der
sitz des amerikanischen kongresses oder
irgendwie sowas oder supreme court in
amerika irgendwie sowas ich habe keine
ahnung ich habe ebenfalls sehr imposant
gebaut ultra massiv dann haben wir
hinten in der ecke noch die römischen
aquädukte das auch sehr sehr gut gemacht
ist sie gehen auch ewig lange hinten
raus sie steht auch drauf akku sollte
zum schluss haben also bei den schäden
gemacht ich will gar nicht zu sehr von
dem export ein bisschen jetzt auch nicht
um geflogen haben was angeschaut wenn
euch die web interessiert wie gesagt
link dazu ist in der beschreibung der
könig selbst herunterladen
sie ist bisschen groß aber es lohnt sich
es macht einfach echt spaß ihre nicht
dass sie so viel spaß macht einfach über
die map zu fliegen dass ich irgendwie
gebäude anzugucken und zu überlegen
geben welches ist das jetzt und so oder
so könnte die auch runterladen auf
irgend server laden damit anfreunden auf
zocken und kann alle besetzt und einer
den reichstag oder so bleibt auf jeden
fall feedback in die kommentare wir so
was findet wenn ich sowas mache und in
diesem sinne
selber und dann wieder am nächsten bank
chef